Квантові комп'ютери вирішують саме ті проблеми, які неможливо розв'язати
класичними комп'ютерами —
наприклад, знайти потрібні матеріали для
вловлювання вуглецю, щоб справді
боротися зі зміною клімату, або знайти
ефективніші добрива, які
не завдають шкоди землі, але водночас підтримують
ланцюг постачання продовольства, необхідний для харчування всього світу.
Є й фундаментальні питання про те, як влаштований наш Всесвіт
і як поводиться матерія на атомному
та субатомному рівнях — і нам потрібно це знати.
Це наступний рубіж.
Розглянемо одну галузь досліджень, яка вже ведеться, —
пошук нових акумуляторів.
Акумулятори змінили наше життя, давши нам змогу носити з собою
комп'ютери та смартфони.
Але попереду ще багато роботи — акумулятори мають вирішальне значення
для нашого чистого енергетичного майбутнього:
живлення електромобілів,
розвиток відновлюваної енергетики.
Нам потрібна принципово інша хімія,
щоб створити акумулятори
майбутнього. Квантові обчислення
дозволили б нам фактично заглянути всередину акумулятора
під час дуже складних реакцій, що відбуваються в ньому, і дати нам можливість
думати про нові матеріали
і структуру акумуляторів, які знадобляться
для живлення пристроїв наступного покоління.
Як ми до цього прийдемо? Будуючи найдосконаліші квантові
пристрої і платформу для розробки,
доступну всьому світу.
Тільки спільними зусиллями сьогодні
ми зможемо вирішити проблеми, з якими нам доведеться
разом стикнутися в майбутньому.